dans mon prochain sujet là vous allez
croire que je suis dans un livre de
science fiction mais je vous jure que
non on est à la chambre des communes
hier les députés canadiens ont approuvé
une motion assez spécial c'est à dire
des modifications qui seront apportées
au code criminel pour permettre des
poursuites pour des crimes qu'ils
seraient commises sur la lune ou en
orbite franchement j'y croyais pas on en
discute avec un vrai un avocat step en
danger qui était avocat criminaliste
bonjour stéphane
rougeot isabelle alors le code criminel
dépasse maintenant l'orbité terrestre
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut prévoir des
nouvelles dispositions
un crime c'est un crime peu importe où
il est commis
en effet le code criminel doit s'adapter
et la société s'adapte adoption de
certaines dispositions le au fur et à
mesure des changements dans la société
puisqu'on talent
avec les masques de seulement mais il
facile de stationner là il faut
s'adapter
la station spatiale
la situation parce que ou bien encore un
détournement d'un vaisseau spatial de
citation on prévoit ces mondes x tafalla
mais c'est pas des nouveaux crimes s'est
livrée crime qui existe dans le code
criminel vous parlez de moeurs vous
parlez de même de fraude lui-même une
une astronaute qui avait accédé au
compte conjoint pendant qu'elle était en
espagne dans l'espace alors c'est pas
des nouveaux crimes mais il faut les
prévoir dans le code criminel
il faut surtout pas des nouveaux crimes
ce qui est nouveau par contre c'est la
territoriale du témoin alors qui a
juridiction lorsqu'un crime qui est bien
là nous sommes en dons parce que le
législateur a prévu dans ces nouvelles
dispositions c'est soit le lieu de
résidence du citoyen qui est comme une
grippe ou soit le lieu de résidence de
la victime du crime ou de du pays qui a
organisé la mission spatiale donc il
serait habité à ce moment elle déposé
des accusations contre le suspect entre
les allégations
justement je me disais ça l'espace est
vaste la lune c'est loin alors on sait
pas il faudra se fit évidemment au
témoin s'il y en a alors c'est un petit
peu possible d'enquêter sur un crime
éventuels qui seraient commis en orbite
ou même à l'intérieur de la station
spatiale
ce me semble ça va compliquer les attend
c'est déjà pas simple sur terre
écoutez à ce moment là on reprendre ce
dans des stations spatiales
souci de faire trop bas on va le fait
aussi qu'il ya sûrement plusieurs
aspects non qui sont à bord de
la station spatiale à ce moment arrive
la mairie de vienne des témoins
oculaires
vous avez également toujours la preuve
circonstancielle à une proportionnalité
par exemple si on voyait des musiques
toutes les autres possibilités
conclure que ça une seule personne qui
peut avoir comme des criminels alors la
presse britannique
une cote de justice bon on disait tantôt
que c'est un crime c'est un crime peu
importe où il est commis mais on signe
de la société s'adapte à la nouveauté
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir des
nouveaux crimes parce que au fil des ans
on en a vu des nouveaux appareils par
exemple les cyber toutes les cybercrimes
cyber harcèlement cyber pédophile his
band simulation n'importe quoi cyber
intimidation alors il ya même des crimes
avec des crypto monnaie alors est ce que
vous imaginez des crimes qui sont
relatifs à l'espace qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être nouveau comme crime je
veux pas donner de mauvaises idées à
personne mais
écoutez dès les nouveaux crimes dans
l'espace vert certainement de famille
tourne
un nouveau crime en soi il ya aussi le
fait de
provoquer l'explosion
de provoquer un baby à l'armée à ce
moment donné ça existe déjà parce que
c'est celle ci pour la db ski
des buffets ou des billets ou peu
importe
mais vous savez l'exploitant
on le voit également dans d'autres
situations
justement je pense que vous allez à
lille là où je voulais vous amener c'est
à dire les eaux internationales
les r je dirais qu'il ya des crimes qui
se commettent quelque part dans les
océans les il doit bien y avoir un
territoire qui est défini
à ce moment-là traiter des eaux
internationales
qui va s'appliquer
du droit international public social la
deuxième chose de talent est aussi celui
des criminels ils ont accueilli par des
individus on voit ça au canada des
séries spéciales qu'on puisse incriminer
accusé un pédophile qui marois les abus
sexuels à l'endroit des enfants dans un
nazi ce soit il a
alors on voit qu'au niveau de
l'intérieur qualité la juridiction doit
y avoir des variations ce
la question de pratique si vous voulez
expression de la preuve selon lui en
fonction du très certainement des
traités qui seront signés entre les pays
qu'ils visitent l'espace et on s'en
reparlera step en danger ça vous ferait
un beau petit mandat ça dans la station
spatiale lunaire merci infiniment nous
en avons parlé aujourd'hui on a bien
au revoir merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh